hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel this video is sponsored by EA
but important note this game rocket
arena is actually part of the EA
originals program which I love I have
absolutely spoken about this videos
before but farnum's doesn't know the
indie development studios who make the
EA Originals games actually take 100% of
the profits from those games this one is
made by final strike games and is out
today cross play on ps4 Xbox one and PC
I'll leave a link in the description
below if you want to check it out
generally a huge fan of this program I
think it's so great for Indies in the
scene but aside from that this is
basically like a very cute looking
cartoonish 3v3 shooter that has some
elements that look a bit like smash so
I'm excited to check those out so let's
jump into the launch of rocket arena
this is the tutorial we'll jump it into
here so look look at me looking you can
jump up to three three times
[Music]
double jump triple jump nailed it I
don't have to shoot at the things that's
pretty dope that's an interesting way of
Eligibility to avoid enemy rocket okay
how to dodge what what is don't sorry
cute huh well you made that very easy
for me what is it this looks like a face
who is this guy what is this war hammer
your bloody angel okay so I guess that
may be the more you do this the harder
it is for them to stay on the platform
it's like smash use you're uniqu
secondary and special abilities I would
love to show me how to do that tools
secondary ability let's go
that's like our little cluster of
rockets a bomb this is cute
I like that that's up my a this is
absolutely like a Dutch person shoot a
version of smash huh interesting
it totally is it's just like everyone's
curvy and they get knocked off the edge
and they just shoot at the walls to jump
back on is that me I didn't give them my
likeness that I mean I don't know blue
eyes but otherwise hang on what no it's
this way she's just identical right we
look the same right yeah I thought no I
didn't realize I have my microphone
sticking out just so you all know I use
like my actual microphone which is here
and this is attached to the cable so I
always just flip it behind and put it in
my hair don't worry about it
I was probably sticking out the whole
time I guess we're starting with this
then okay well this is the one that I've
decided is when I like I like Marshall
Rendell top notch sorry what was his
name
it's top notch I think he said his name
was like Marshall Randall top notch
which I love
I am very into like a wizard Lee look an
old man 3 2 1 knockout opponents to win
I thought you'd never ask
sound design is cute I'm sorry what what
is this
Oh enhance Dodge that's pretty sick I
wasn't using a Dodge actually
[Music]
big hit come on get out of here not
today Kirby good day sir hey hey hey
yeah I'm not using my dodge as much as I
should be
now that was sick
I'm gonna go for this item box like this
merio kit you'll see the hip all right
where everybody at
anyone get out of here get out of here
get out of here get out of here bye Oh
what if I done uh-oh I got I got speed
got it okay I got a KO a cyst that's
that's cool thing we like to see
come on no it's satisfying
I shouldn't have done that I just
totally wasted my special
tripmine what that seems like terrible
placement I got too excited by the
prompted Preston why did you just play a
reggae hold why is that happen we do you
cool
she's very dapper you know I didn't use
that sword once so it's the opportunity
to sword because if there is I will
literally always take it you guys I
think we finally found the game when
maybe I might go pro so goodbye regular
each team uploads I think that instead
I'm going to become a rocket arena
[Music]
welcome you on I would like to play
against real humans which one do I want
to do 3v3 social matchmaking freebie
three social knockout matchmaking
let's do arena
[Music]
what genre is this it's like it's
country but with no vocals it's like Oh
Kestrel country all right let's find out
how much of it pro I actually am
remember there's a star of creative mega
rocket capture mega rockets to win okay
that's a mechanic this need to be editor
let's go sauce I'm gonna go right breath
it me I am rather let's kick this into
gear okay so he's like a pirate
BAM oh well that's too cool 302 I'm
green couplet one capture five mega
rocket what does that mean though oh
it's literally just like a point
damn right I dodged a rocket trying to
capture the thing you know you keep
yourself treating me you know
dammit where's my team you know just
play the objective rocket you are almost
out cuz you get out of here get out of
get get outta get out of here I want it
I want the win I want the chaos rocket
walls we're not doing good team when I'm
doing good one mega rocket to win
incoming mega rocket hey got a KO but we
capturing this one oh my god finally
I need you to die let's just go grab
this one right Oh try to grab the item
avail is no we put too much damage there
that was a lot
I don't like my girls special ability so
instead I'm going to go to practice and
test out different heroes I try
what's the name Isaiah Isaiah that's a
lot of hair that must basically God oh I
like that
okay what'swhat's the election okay
which is sort of like what the other
chicks was it like it makes you home
which I wasn't a huge fan of I think
because the actual players just move too
much
choose your competitor
oh the pirate boy I like him he has the
face of a gerbil well so that's a lot of
just a lot of chunk do the rocket Boris
what is your oh that's sick yes yes we
like that we are into that don't like
the movement based ones this is this is
like yeah it's like an explosion right
around and I'm super into that tripmine
oh that's how that would have worked if
I had placed it the right way the first
time
goodbye his shooting is interesting
because it involves a lot so when
they're in the air it's on a time but I
like his play style I'm into that fish
hole plink let's fire up the strap
rockets okay let's do it do the rocket
box
[Music]
is it tell opponent oh that's pretty
cool
okay let's I'm gonna try nice Attila for
grabs with that that's pretty neat that
sounded like a more offensive character
that's pretty cool
by I tried you guys it's such a problem
we indigo that one matching with that
character that I wasn't a fan of using
but yeah I guess this this beta does
close in half an hour so that's probably
just not many people left on which is a
huge bummer game comes out on the 14th I
do think this is something that I will
play again actually I think this is
probably a great game play for fun house
to do and yeah thank you to e the
sponsoring this video I'm a lot of I'll
see you guys next night